the German defendant known as Nadine K
arrived in court covering her face from
the cameras to hear the verdict at the
end of this sixth month trial
sat opposite her just a few feet away
was Naveen Al the young yazidi woman who
she kept as a slave for five years and
whose evidence was crucial in convicting
her
Nadine K went to Syria and joined
Islamic State with her husband in 2014.
he is now in prison in Syria
during her five years as an is slave
Naveen here on the left was sexually
assaulted tortured forced to work for
the couple and pressed to convert to
Islam which he refused to do
she told her story exclusively to Sky
News
foreign
Naveen was found in a camp in Syria by a
Scottish filmmaker he helped her Escape
back to Iraq
we spent time with Naveen her family
near their home in Iraq and showed her
for the first time a video of the moment
that she was finally safe
mode
but
thousands of yazidis are still missing
and many remain buried in Mass Graves
Levine told us that Justice today was
Justice for her and for all yazidis who
suffered because of Islamic State
Aleister bunkel Sky News